so yeah I was just on a another show
this weekend they asked me about my bus
to battle because me and Buster went at
it uh one night at the tunnel I probably
told this story 50 times I'm at a red
light Buster pulls up besides me and you
shout out Buster cause you know he just
got the big award lifetime achievement
for sure and I only tell the story
because
he deserves everything he has right now
who he isn't also because he's still
that dude that's gonna get at you when
it's time to flex your [__] right so I'm
at a red light Buster pulls up beside me
you know we're at the tunnel nightclub
where you Circle the block looking for
parking I guess they doing the same so
when he pulled up beside me he's in the
passenger seat I'm in the driver's seat
of my truck
and I looked and I said boy so you want
a battle [__] that [__] looked at me
and said what
I said pull over [__] he said no and he
started spitting
and went at it yo he was going so hard
that the light turned green and
everything now we got traffic backed up
all the horns you guys are battling
through the car windows through the car
window then we pulled over and went at
it for like an hour you and Busta Rhymes
me and Buster I didn't even have a demo
outside the tunnel outside the tunnel
nightclub in New York City like on 11th
Avenue you had to guess was this it was
right when he began to promote the woo
ha single it hasn't dropped yet first
album Buster this is first single before
the scenario remix yep buzzing yep so
this is that buster but like I said man
he he got busy so these are the people
that really lived that [__] that's why
it's nothing for them they don't feel
disrespected because he's also built
that way that's what he comes from I say
the same about Coolio and there was a
lot of rappers that when you know
because they got out to the point I
would go to the tunnel every week and I
stopped going inside I'm sitting outside
with my truck everybody who walked up
I'm stepping to him I remember Pudgie's
a fat bastard walked up one day you know
I'm like you know you got to do this
with me right now pudgy we got to get
this in and we moved off to the side you
know we rap back and forth but you know
he was focused on getting up in the club
you know but they would how crazy was
the tunnel oh man you had to be a thug
to go up in there or pretty lady
because you know I've been going to the
tunnel since the 80s the 80s was popping
with the tongue in my head I just think
of people in like
like puffy Goose jackets Timberlands and
you know [__] scullies
some of that but whatever the trends
were at that time a lot of jewelry gold
chains you know and and the thing was it
was full of like all the thugs from all
the different projects and neighborhoods
right stick up kids wait outside of the
tunnel hell yeah
matter of fact like a couple of blocks
away there's a project near there those
dudes were eating yeah because a lot not
everybody had a car there's New York
city so you would have to drive I mean
you would take the train and maybe walk
the five or six blocks through their
area and they knew that that was these
[__] was robbing dudes all the
time you know but there was also dudes
that circled the block waiting for you
to come out Friday night Saturday night
that was a Sunday night Sunday nights at
the tunnel
that's crazy shout out to the tunnel I
just the only thing I know about the
tunnel is it was a hell of a funk flex
and big cap album
rest in peace the big cap rest in peace
cap well listen I appreciate you man uh
the new album's out right now I thought
skill is traded All Digital platforms
like I said check the website Thurston
Howell the third.com check my YouTube
page watch all my movies or my videos
I'm on IG Facebook thirsting how the
Third on everything you know what I mean
and uh hopefully we get the story of the
lowlifes soon hope is here baby it's
coming hope is here hope is alive so I
can't wait to see it yeah nah who would
you uh cast to play yourself I got a
couple of people in mind I don't want to
say yeah so that way I don't put them on
points or where they trying to figure
out how much to hit me in the head for
okay you know I mean but I got some good
ones you know we've been pursuing this
story for over 20 years like myself and
Mark 11 from blowback Productions and in
the beginning in the early 2000s I had
chosen Rick Gonzalez to play me you know
and he was the
yeah the only problem is now is that you
know he's he's older and this is this is
a young role he's a rapper from what I
recall yeah yeah Rick is busy man and uh
he would have been he to me he's still
perfect but the role was for it begins
as a 16 year old kid yeah I feel like
you need somebody kind of like
relatively unknown and that's exactly
what we've gone into this role to change
their career trajectory that's exactly
how we're thinking man we want to give
somebody that opportunity a second
snowfall like nobody like now that dude
is the hottest and that show put him in
a place you know the wire the wire the
wires how many actors from The Wire can
we say but Idris is the one that
actually it put him on the map no no I'm
saying damn San Andreas is a different
guy than Idris Elba okay uh damsonitrus
is the young kid from the UK that played
Franklin Saint in snowfall oh
Elba the wire Stringer Bell changed his
life now why is and Michael K Williams
life yeah and so many actors I mean I
can't I mean
that's what we hoping to do man we want
to break ground I want I want a Puerto
Rican actor to play me I want to get
that low-key be like the
that era of New York's version of The
Wire because it needs that
that's where we going with it baby
because it's so many stories within the
story yeah there's so many different you
know there's so many moving Parts in it
yeah and there's so many sides so you
know it's gonna go to so many different
angles man like even what we have
prepared already is like wow right you
know well [__] I can't wait to see it
man we appreciate you coming through
you're ready go uh support what's the
website one more time Thurston Howell
the third.com shout out all the low life
family all over the world you know I
mean the URL the rlpc the Orlando low
Zone the Miami family low life Mexico
low life Paris low life wash